[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi.
And welcome to episode number
50 of the weekly Google Cloud
Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc Campoy.
And I'm here with my
colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm a bit sleepy.
But I'm good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's been a long day,
many meanings, many recordings.
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Busy time of year.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, but
actually very good interview
today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It was super--
actually it was great.
It was just really great.
We talked to two
members of Deis.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Deis.
MARK MANDEL: Deis.
Working on the Helm project, the
package manager for Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
it is very interesting.
I really enjoyed the whole
conversation, lots of history
about the project, how it
happened, and how to use it.
And I'm actually now convinced.
I want to try it.
I'm definitely using this.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and going
on from that, actually after we
talk to our people
for our interview,
we have a question of the week
about building Docker images
in the cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
That is interesting, especially
if you're traveling around
and you have Wi-Fi
from the hotel.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Or on an airplane.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh
yeah, I have tried.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I've built Docker
images while using Gogo.
It kind of works.
It works.
I mean, it works.
I've done it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, if
you have a long flight--
the flight is long enough.
Cool.
But before that, we have
the cool things of the week,
as usual.
And the first one is about my
favorite sport, not at all.
I actually don't know much
about this sport, it's baseball.
It's about decoding the
micro-moments of baseball.
Can you hear the
games through data?
So yeah, this is
basically just a blog post
that was announced on Thursday,
October 25 by Eric Schmidt,
one of our latest people to join
our team of developer advocates
for Google Cloud.
And he wrote an
article about how
to basically try to
understand better
what goes on in baseball games.
And to do that, he's using
three big data products.
So he's using Cloud Dataflow
to transform the data.
So Cloud Dataflow,
you can imagine it
as streams of data
going around and kind
of doing MapReduce-y things.
But it is actually
more generic then that.
It is really powerful.
So have a look at it.
I think we-- did we
have an episode on this?
MARK MANDEL: No.
Oh, did we?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm not sure now.
MARK MANDEL: We've done
a lot of episodes now.
So it's actually
getting hard to track.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, maybe we should.
I think that Google Cloud
Dataflow is one of my-- I've
said this before, I think.
It's the only product at Google
that will make me write Java.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
No, it's actually a
really cool article.
They've got stuff in here
answering questions like,
is this pitcher
performing at his best?
Or what was the probability
of the triple play?
Which I think is actually kind
of hard questions to answer.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
the cool about this
is that you basically
want something
that is kind of real
time because you
want to be able to
answer questions
while the game is going on.
So Cloud Dataflow allows you
doing that with streaming.
And then to query all
the data you end up with,
he uses BigQuery.
And to be able to visualize
it in a nice way or to slice
and get only the piece
of data he cares about,
he uses Google Cloud Datalab.
And Google Cloud Datalab,
if you have never used it,
it is pretty much like IPython
or Jupyter pages on the cloud.
It is very, very
useful, especially
because then you can just say,
run a little MapReduce here.
And it will create the
whole thing for you.
MARK MANDEL: That's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It's very nice.
Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Sweet.
Well, we have one more cool
thing of the week that flows
on quite nicely from our Windows
and .NET episode yesterday.
It was showing how you can use
PowerShell to basically treat
Google Cloud Storage
like local storage.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
by yesterday, Mark
means last week.
MARK MANDEL: I mean last week.
I am really tired.
I don't know what day it is
anymore or what is going on.
But that's fine.
But no, it's really nice.
So yeah, if you're
using PowerShell
and you want to interact
with Google Cloud Storage,
you can use things
like cd and-- I
keeping wanting to ls
because I'm a Linux user.
But like cd and standard
Microsoft Windows-y type
directory stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know dir.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
Seriously, I haven't
done that in so long.
Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
that's pretty much it.
I don't remember any of them.
Yeah, it is actually
really cool because, I
mean, if you are
a PowerShell user,
basically this will allow
you to use Google Cloud
Storage in a very native
and intuitive way.
MARK MANDEL: It's cool.
Because basically, the
PowerShell provider,
it returns the same
objects as everything else.
So you can intermix
commands and do stuff
like you would do normally.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
really like-- there's
this sentence in the blog
post that says, you can't just
treat Google Cloud Storage
like a really, really,
really big hard disk.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is what it is.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It is really big.
MARK MANDEL: It is really big.
Excellent.
Well, why don't we go have a
chat with the two clever people
that we have from Helm?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
very happy to welcome
two people from Deis.
Did I say it correctly?
Did I mess it up already?
Deis.
Whatever.
They'll tell us.
So we have Michelle
Noorali, Software Engineer.
Hi.
How are you doing?
MICHELLE NOORALI: Great.
How are you?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And we
also have Matt Butcher,
a Software Architect
at "di-us" or "day-us"?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: "Day-us."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Deis.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
That is a hard one.
So we're going to be talking
a little bit about something
pretty cool.
But before we start talking
about the main topic,
why don't you tell us a
little bit about who are you
and what you do at Deis?
We can start with Michelle.
MICHELLE NOORALI: Yeah.
So I am Michelle.
I'm a developer at Deis.
I'm a core maintainer on
the Kubernetes Helm project.
I also co-lead the Kubernetes
Special Interest Group
for Applications, which
is more commonly referred
to as SIG-Apps.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
What about you, Matt?
MATTHEW BUTCHER:
I'm Matt Butcher.
I'm an architect at Deis.
I'm one of the core
contributors on the Helm project
and one of the people who
kind of came up with the ideas
behind Helm.
Along with working
at Deis, I also
teach occasionally at
Loyola University Chicago
in the CS Department there.
And I just recently finished
a book called "Go in Practice"
on Go software
development, co-authored
that with Matt Farina.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And obviously, you have
a PhD in philosophy?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Yeah.
All those people would
tell you that's worthless.
Actually the trick is
to go from philosophy
into software development.
That's how--
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
you know what?
Not the first time
I've heard that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: We
should do an episode
on the philosophy
of Go routines.
MARK MANDEL: There we go.
That sounds great.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That would
be an interesting one.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, cool.
All right so Matt, you sound
like maybe the right person.
From a high level what is Helm?
What does it do?
What is it for?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: So Helm is a
package manager for Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes is this great
system, comes out at Google,
kind of based on
Google's board project.
And it's a great tool for
running applications inside
of a large-scale cluster.
But one of our early
pain points with it
was that it's hard to set up
your applications to install
them into Kubernetes.
So we looked around,
and we looked
at how we do this in Linux,
how we do it in OS 10.
We looked at Homebrew for OS 10
and Yum and apt-get for Linux.
And we said, you know
what would be really cool?
To build something like
that for Kubernetes that
made it possible to
express the stuff
you wanted to run in Kubernetes
as an application package
that you could share
and reuse and stuff.
So at a high level, yeah,
it's a package manager
designed for Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: So what
sort of applications
would I be looking to deploy?
Can you give me some examples?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Yeah.
Actually, I'll let
Michelle answer this.
MICHELLE NOORALI: Sure.
You could install a
variety of applications,
WordPress, Jenkins, Databases,
MySQL, [INAUDIBLE], Postgres.
So really, there's
a large range.
MARK MANDEL: So cool.
So I guess that means I'm like,
oh, I need a MySQL database.
I don't have to
work out the details
of how to set that up and best
practices and things like that.
I can just go to Helm and be
like, Helm, install MySQL,
or something like that.
MICHELLE NOORALI: Yeah, you
could grab the Helm binary
and run a search command
and do helm search mysql.
And you'll have a
variety of options.
And then you can tweak
your MySQL configuration
to your preferences
and then run install
to install the actual chart.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
the question I always
have when I think about these
kind of deployment managers--
which I really see it as
something that helps you deploy
an application into Kubernetes--
is the default value the best
practice?
If I just say yes, yes, yes,
yes, yes, I will have something
that actually works
in production?
Or is it something
to get started?
And then you're
going to be tuning up
the deployment to have something
that matches your use case?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: I
guess I look at them as
like your etc files on Linux.
When you first
install something,
you want it to
function enough so
that you've got a starting point
to sort of tweak it from there.
But is the default always
going to be the best?
Probably not.
So the trick is as
chart developers
is to write these kinds
of Helm chart packages
that are good enough to get
people kind of up and running
and then help them
understand from there how
they have to tweak it.
Now the additional problem
with cluster-based software
is that when you're installing
something via Homebrew,
you know you're going to have
one instance running locally
on exactly one computer
every time you type that in.
Well, when you're dealing
with something like a cluster,
you may want to be running
one instance of Postgres,
for example.
Or you may want to be running a
cluster of six Postgres servers
with a master elected
out of that pool
or something like that.
So the trick with setting up
defaults, sensible defaults,
is to sort of intuit what the
base case is for most users.
And then make it
easy enough that they
can extend it off the base
case with very little effort.
MARK MANDEL: So you
use a word there.
You said the word chart.
Michelle, do you want to
explain what a chart is?
What is that?
MICHELLE NOORALI: Yeah,
so a chart is basically
a package format for Helm.
It's a directory
structure that consists
of some metadata,
templated or not
templated, Kubernetes resources,
and some documentation.
And so applications come
in the form of charts.
And then you install charts
into your cluster using Helm.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Why
are they called charts?
MICHELLE NOORALI: Oh,
that's a very good question.
Matt Butcher, I'm going
to let you take that one.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Well, so when
we very first started the Helm
project, our first name
for it was actually
K8S Place, K-8-S Place, which
we thought was kind of cute.
MICHELLE NOORALI: I loved it.
Sorry.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: And the
original name of the package
was something like K Cubed,
K3 or something like that.
It was really pretentious.
And as we got talking about
it, we thought, all right.
So we've got this
cute name, K8S Place
and this pretentious
package name.
And neither of them really
fit the nautical theme
of Kubernetes, where Kubernetes
really means a pilot of a ship.
So we hit the
nautical dictionary.
One of the co-founders of the
project, Jack Francis, and I
hit a nautical
dictionary and sat around
for about an hour
reading definitions,
trying to come up with
a new name for the tool.
And we eventually alighted on
Helm as the name for the tool.
And then once we were going
with this nautical dictionary,
we couldn't let
good enough rest.
So we decided to
rename the package too.
And we were kind
of thinking, well,
this is sort of like a
road map or a street map
for how you would install
something into Kubernetes.
And the CEO of Deis is a big
sailor himself, enjoys boating.
And he said, you do not
talk about them as maps.
They're charts, nautical charts.
And the name stuck.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a nice name I like it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: I was
going to say, it's short.
It's catchy.
It's relatively direct
as far as conveying
that you're providing
a set of instructions
for how to do something.
MARK MANDEL: I guess
that segues kind of
into an interesting thing as
well, the history of Helm.
I think there was Helm.
And then there was
Deployment Manager.
And now there's Helm Classic
or they melded and merged.
Like what happened there?
I didn't quite follow it all.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Yeah, it's
actually a really cool history.
It's one you don't get a lot
in the open source world.
So a little over a year ago now,
Deis started this Helm project.
It actually came
out of a hackathon.
We were having an "all
hands off site" meeting.
And we set up a hackathon
to try and come up
with some good competitive
projects to build teamwork
and just enjoy
some time together.
So we formed these
kind of ad hoc teams.
And we were building stuff.
Well, my team built this
little package manager-y thing,
the K8S Place I was
talking about before.
And the off-site ended.
And we all went home.
And it was a Friday afternoon.
And I got a call from
the CTO saying, you know,
that little hackathon
project has some potential.
Maybe we should start
to actually develop it.
And so the following
Monday after he got back,
we formed up a new team
and started going on this.
Now what we didn't
know at the time
was that several Google
engineers were also
working on a similar
project, which
was a port of the JCP Deployment
Manager project to Kubernetes.
And so for a few months,
we were roughly running
in parity with them.
And our emphasis at the time
was the client side experience.
We were trying to build Homebrew
where a lot of the packages
are just downloaded locally.
And then you're really oriented
around the relationship
between an individual
user and a chart,
which is what we were
calling them at that point.
Whereas, Deployment Manager
was really dealing more
with the process of deployment
and the process of allowing
a team to together
collaborate on
how something could be deployed
and then updated and maintained
over its lifetime.
So that was about
October for us last year.
Deployment Manager, I think,
had its first public releases
on November 1, if
I recall correctly.
Well, sometime around
January, Google Seattle
invited us to come up.
And the developers of Deployment
Manager sat down with us.
And we talked about
how we might be
able to do something
that happens very
rarely in the open source world,
which is to merge two projects.
And so we put together a really
rough plan there and sort of
re-kickstarted the project off.
And we all liked the
Helm name because it
was relatively distinctive.
So we kept that and sort
of rebranded as Helm.
And then gradually, what
was the Helm client,
stayed the Helm client.
But what was the
Deployment Manager server
became Tiller, which
is the server side
component, the cluster side
component of Helm right now.
Well, in the process
of all of this,
well, we had this original
tool that was already
kind of popular called Helm.
And so we rebranded
that one to Helm Classic
so that people could
still continue using it
while we explored uncharted
waters, to keep playing up
this nautical metaphor.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, wow.
MATTHEW BUTCHER:
Yeah, there you go.
I'm loaded with them.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, the fun.
Oh, the fun.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Yeah.
And so Helm Classic was kind
of the original version of it.
And then the Kubernetes
Helm version,
which is in the
Kubernetes project
and is incubated as an official
Kubernetes project, that's
the one that we're really
moving forward and firing
full steam ahead on.
MICHELLE NOORALI: More of those.
More of those.
MARK MANDEL: Wow.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: I know.
I'm going to just keep trying
these nautical metaphors
until I run out of them.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I am
looking forward the next.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Me too.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So I had a question
regarding the point of view.
So you were talking that Helm
has a deep focus on the user,
on the customer.
But I am curious
about what if I have
an application that I would like
to offer on Helm as a chart?
What is the process to do that?
MICHELLE NOORALI: Yeah, so
there's two ways to publish,
or two avenues you can
take to publish your chart.
And the first one is you
can build your own chart
repository.
So charts live in
chart repositories,
which are just simple
HTTP servers that
follow a particular format.
Or you can submit your chart
to the Kubernetes chart
repository.
And so if you go to
github.com/kubernetes/charts,
we have the source code for
stable charts and incubator
charts that people have
submitted over the last few
months to share
with the community.
And so if you have a chart
that you-- is working
and you want to get
feedback on, you
might submit it to the
incubator chart repository.
And if you have more of a
production-ready chart that
meets deep technical
requirements,
then you would submit it to
the stable chart repository.
MARK MANDEL: So what
actually goes into a chart?
Can you go a little--
if I'm writing
one, is there a template
language or something?
What's the--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Is it a YAML file?
MARK MANDEL: Is it a YAML file?
Yeah.
What's the deal?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: It's
everything a YAML file now?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, hopefully.
MARK MANDEL: Hopefully.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Not JSON anymore.
MICHELLE NOORALI: I'm
going to let Butcher take
that one because he developed--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fair enough.
MICHELLE NOORALI: --all of that.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: I was going
to let you take that one so I
didn't have to answer it.
MICHELLE NOORALI: I don't mind.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: So a chart is
a bundle of plain text files,
really for the most part.
It references a
Docker image that's
got to be pushed to
a registry somewhere,
or could reference a
Docker image, I should say.
But really, it's got
a control manifest.
It sort of tells you information
about the chart, readme file
and notes file that tell you
kind of how to use the chart.
And then for the most part,
the real meat of the chart
is a set of YAML templates.
There you go.
There's the YAML.
We use the Go template
language to be
able to populate YAML files.
And then we can upload the YAML
files directly into Kubernetes.
And Kubernetes understands
those files natively.
So the Go template language
has been pretty nice for us
because it compiles very
well and usually gives
relatively helpful
error messages
and is very fast for us.
And we can sandbox
it very efficiently
without having to worry about
breakout conditions and things.
But you know, your typical
chart runs probably
four templates and then
the chart.YAML control file
and then a couple of text
files to explain how to use it.
Oh, and actually in
order to kind of get
started with it-- because I know
you lead with that question--
we originally realized that--
or we realized very quickly
that it's a pain to keep writing
YAML files over and over again.
And on top of that,
that there are
a lot of patterns
that really are
common across many, many charts.
So we built a command called
Helm Create that will allow
you to create a new chart.
So you can type in
Helm Create WordPress.
And you'll have a stubbed
out chart ready to go.
And then you can just
modify it from there
instead of having to
start afresh each time.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
So say I've written
my chart or I've
gone to look at, what is it,
the stable or the incubating
charts.
And I want to install one.
What does that look like?
MICHELLE NOORALI: So
when you install the Helm
tool, by default we give you
access to the stable charts.
So you can simply do a helm
search on whatever keyword.
Or you can do a helm search and
pass in the repository name.
And you'll see all of the
charts that are available.
And then if you want to add,
say, your friend's chart
repository to search
through those as well,
then you can run a helm repo add
command to add that repository.
And then you can search
through those as well.
MARK MANDEL: And can I
pass variables through?
I know you said it was a
sort of templating thing.
What sort of controls
do I have there?
MATTHEW BUTCHER:
Yeah, so by default
when you're setting
up your templates,
one of the files that's
good to provide with it
is sort of a default
values file, which
is called values.YAML
because we're really
into our YAML files.
And the values.YAML
is basically,
you can think of it sort of like
as the etc file for your chart.
It contains YAML data that
gets pushed by default
through the template engine.
But more than that, it's
sort of like a way for us
to expose to
developers, hey, here
are the different little options
that you can tweak and change
easily with this chart by just
passing in your own custom YAML
file or your own
custom YAML values when
you run the installer.
So say I've got my
WordPress chart.
And I want to
create my admin user
account when I do the install.
I don't want the default
password for that account.
So when I type in the
helm install command,
I can either give it a YAML
overrides file that will
override the configuration
for that and maybe set
username:mbutcher for that.
Or I can use the set
flag on the command line
and set very particular
configuration parameters.
But in either case,
really what we're doing
is we're allowing the
end-user, the person who's
consuming the chart,
to be able to specify
some of their own configuration
custom right from the get-go.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
I got a fun question.
If I do a helm install,
is it idempotent?
Yeah, if I'm trying to
set up some infrastructure
and I'm automating
it and I just want
to keep running it over and
over again, is that the way
it works?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: So we
actually-- originally,
we didn't do it that way.
But over time, it has
been more and more
popular to be able to deploy
Helm charts via CI/CD.
And so we have introduced,
first of all, a renewed effort
to try and make them
more idempotent and also
added some additional
flags in there
that will allow you
to run one command.
So helm install will put
your chart into the cluster.
And it'll start tracking
that chart over time.
So you can recover
history and so on.
And then helm update
is used to kind
of re-release over and
over or release updates.
You change a
configuration value.
You run an update.
You go from version
1.2.3 to 1.3.4.
You run an update.
But in order to make it possible
to run it through a CI/CD
system over and over
again without having
to query the cluster
first, we just
added some flags onto the
update command that basically,
if you do helm update --install,
it tells update, hey, try
and update this.
But if it already exists,
just install it first.
MARK MANDEL: If
it already exists?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: If it doesn't--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
If it doesn't exit.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Did
I get it backwards?
Yeah.
I got it backwards.
Install it if it doesn't exist.
Update it if it does.
There we go.
Yeah, I know my-- I can speak.
MICHELLE NOORALI: Also,
that command is upgrade.
So just-- update.
MATTHEW BUTCHER:
And I said update.
Didn't I?
Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
So helm upgrade install.
MICHELLE NOORALI: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I have a question.
Before we were talking
about Helm as a way
for application
developers basically
to provide an easy way to
deploy their application
onto Kubernetes.
But now you're
talking about CI/CD.
It makes me think.
Is it also a good
tool for someone
like a company
that they're using
their own system to deploy it
on Kubernetes through CI/CD?
Could that be easier than
just using Kubernetes files,
just playing Kubernetes
config files?
MATTHEW BUTCHER: I
think that the way that
CI/CD systems get used
is as sort of a-- well,
for sure kind of last mile
piece of your equation.
So as a developer, I need
to build my application.
Then I want to be able to
test it locally and figure out
how it's going to work.
Then I want to contribute
it up to the repo.
And then the CI/CD system
takes over from there.
And what Helm gives you-- the
advantage that Helm really
confers in this process over,
say, just raw manifest files,
actually there's several.
But the first one is that
it gives the developer
that opportunity to fully
test out and work together--
work this whole thing together,
share it with other developers
and things like that prior
to it ever getting deployed.
But then once we get into
the release pipeline,
this is where a
chart ends up being
very powerful because
a chart is basically
immutable from the
time you package it up
where it can get tracked, first
of all, inside of the cluster
but also in these chart
repositories elsewhere.
And so I can-- if I'm pushing
things into repositories
and then pulling
them out in CI/CD,
I've got the exact records in
the repository of what thing
I pulled out.
And I can pull it out,
rebuild it, and so on.
I've seen a lot of cases
where people very successfully
use just raw Kubernetes manifest
files in their CI/CD system.
But where it becomes problematic
for them is in the development
process, where
oftentimes, we end up--
we fall back to the old school
model of throwing applications
over the wall, where developers
develop the application.
And another team is responsible
for-- the DevOps team
is responsible for packaging
that and then somehow pushing
it out to the cluster.
But then when you come
up with those bugs
that seem to
inevitably arise where
something fails as it
goes through the staging
or production process.
And the developer simply says,
hey, I only wrote the binary.
The rest of that stuff is yours.
And then there's this
long back and forth over
whose responsibility it is and
what your particular compliance
regulations say you can see
about the production logs
versus, and-- We feel
like by packaging things
just like Debian and
Fedora and all of those
have done for
years and years, we
gain all those
advantages of being
able to reproduce
locally, reproduce
the same exact thing in
a testing environment
and then in production.
MARK MANDEL: I guess that
makes a lot of sense too.
It kind of solves
that problem that I've
seen where locally I want to
have two instances of this
and two instances of that
and one instance of that.
But then in production, I
want to have 300 of this
and 300 of that.
And so now you can-- maybe
your defaults are two,
but you're production
environment variables
are at 300.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So my next question
is, can I deploy to MINICUBE?
MICHELLE NOORALI: Yes, you can.
Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
That makes for a very
interesting development
experience.
I guess.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I
really want to try this.
This actually is just
really, really cool.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: I think about
half of the development team
uses MINICUBE for their
development process.
We try and mix it
up a little bit.
But honestly, the barrier
to entry for MINICUBE
is so low that we all
sort of favor it and don't
like trying to set
up local Kubernetes
clusters from scratch
or anything like that.
But between MINICUBE and
GKE, the Kubernetes world
is just way too easy
to get going on now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: I want to
talk about-- I think
it's really interesting and
a fairly important thing too,
I believe you can sign
charts so they're verified
from where they come from.
Can one of you tell us a
little bit more about that?
MATTHEW BUTCHER:
Yeah, Michelle is
going to point at me because
this is one of the things
that I have been
rather insistent on.
It is often the case
that we forget about some
of the security
measures to begin with.
And then we try and
retrofit them back in later.
And we're always
afraid of doing that.
I'm sure we're
going to have to do
that in some areas or another.
But one of the things we
decided we wanted to not
overlook at the beginning
was the trust factor
when it came to packages.
So in thinking through this
thing, we thought, all right.
Well, we want to
make it so that there
are ways to establish
trust where you can say,
I know this package
came from so and so.
And I know that it hasn't
been modified since then.
But on the flipside,
we wanted to make it
so that people who were not--
who were in the development
cycle or who didn't particularly
care about that kind of thing
didn't have to use it.
And so we came up
with a model that
allows for signing
of packages and also
allows you to sort of optionally
enable this kind of workflow
so that it becomes sort
of standard for you.
So the way we modeled it was
really after Debian's model
with a little bit of
looking at Yum and the way
that Red Hat has done
it for a long time.
And we sign packages
with PGP keys
so that we can
establish some identity.
And the clear sign block
contains the SHA256SUMS
of the files that are
included so you can
verify those sort of things.
Very, very, very traditional,
uninspired someone
once told me in regard to this.
MARK MANDEL: That's fine.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: And
I went, well, OK.
Well, uninspired is OK
in security, I think.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MATTHEW BUTCHER:
So you can choose
to sign your charts if you want.
And then you can choose
to verify your charts when
you install them if you want.
And then more
recently, we've been
working on sort of
integrating this tool
chain with things like Keybase.
I'm really excited
about Keybase because it
makes public key
cryptography sort
of easy for non-cryptographers,
easy to gain trust
on your identity, easy
to integrate your GPG
key with a reliable key signing
authority, stuff like that.
And so we've been working
a little bit on that.
But then at the end
of the day, we've
been trying to figure
out sort of how--
now that we've got
these primitives-- how
do organizations want to be
able to use this technology?
And so we've tried to
keep it unopinionated
but then be able to give people
some guidance in how you should
issue your keys and how you
should sign your packages
and how you should tell
people how to do that.
That's going to be an
ongoing challenge for us
up through the 2.0
release, I think.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So since we're talking about
2.0 releases and the future,
why don't you-- could
you share something
that you're very excited
about, the roadmap?
MICHELLE NOORALI: Being able
to test your charts once you've
installed them automatically,
that is something
that I'm super pumped about.
So you can install
your chart and then run
a test command that has some
pre-defined definitions of what
it means for success-- or
for a successful installation
of your chart.
Being able to do that
in an automated way
is something that I'm
very pumped about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about you, Matt?
MATTHEW BUTCHER:
I'm honestly looking
forward to hitting the
stability marker because it'll
give me a little bit of a
break from implementing stuff.
But I think other than testing,
which I am really, really
excited about.
Michelle's plan for
that is really cool.
I think that what I'm
kind of looking forward to
is getting to focus
a little bit more
on the developer experience
for the person who's actually
writing the code that's
going to get packaged up
into these applications.
Because as a Python
developer, it
would be nice to be able to have
some tools, even if they are
Metatools that sit on top of
Helm that will help me get
from my little
block of Python code
to a containerized application
with a chart scaffolding around
it that I can deploy with
the helm install command.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, we are running out
of time a little bit.
But I do want to
touch on one thing.
So if people want to
get involved with Helm
or they want to try Helm,
what are the best resources?
Where should people go?
MICHELLE NOORALI: Yeah, the
GitHub repository is definitely
the best place to start.
And all of their released
binaries are there.
You can use Homebrew to
download Helm and install Helm.
The Slack channel
is really active.
I looked yesterday,
and there were
466 people in the Helm channel
in the Kubernetes Slack.
And everybody's very actively
discussing and analyzing
chart design patterns
and figuring things
out and bouncing
ideas off each other.
So that's a great place to
go if you've got questions
and as always, the issue queue.
I do highly
recommend, because I'm
biased, to come to the
SIG-Apps meetings on Mondays.
Matt usually gives us
a Helm update there.
And there have
been several demos
of charts and Helm
being used in CI/CD
and really all over the place.
So if you want to see use cases,
SIG-Apps is the place to go.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: SIG-Apps
is also a great place
just to see cool
demos of what people
are doing with Kubernetes.
It's a great entry
point into Kubernetes.
MICHELLE NOORALI: Yeah,
the focus of SIG-Apps
is mainly to share
with the community
how to define, run, and manage
applications in Kubernetes.
And so it's a mix of
Kubernetes users and Kubernetes
developers.
And what we get is this rich
feedback loop of users saying
here are the tools we're using.
And here the problems
we're running into.
And developers going, well,
I can fix your problem.
Or let me know what
features you want
and discussing those
kinds of things.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right.
We are definitely
running out of time.
But is there
anything else that we
haven't talked about that you
want to talk about quickly
that hasn't been touched on or
a feature that you think should
be publicly talked about?
MATTHEW BUTCHER:
Oh well, for sure
we should thank the
community around Helm
because it was-- like I said, I
can't think of many open source
projects that have formed by
two other projects combining
together.
And people have just dropped
in to help all over the place
from dozens of companies.
Bitnami and Google,
in particular,
have contributed vast amounts
of help and resources.
Bitnami and Google
together have now
taken over ownership of the
charts repository, which
has been fabulous.
And we just-- every day
we watch people come in.
Sometimes they make a one
line commit to the dock.
Sometimes they just bring up
situations we've never heard.
It's a really fun, laid
back, and awesome community.
And we'd be remiss if
we didn't thank them
every opportunity we had
because it's just such a fun
thing to do day after day.
MARK MANDEL: Michelle?
MICHELLE NOORALI: I have to
say the same thing, actually.
This is my first time
being a part of a larger
scale open source community.
And it's been a
fantastic experience.
I've gotten the chance
and the opportunity
to meet so many cool people
from different companies that
just want to help.
And that's been a fantastic
experience for me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That is awesome.
I think that is a great way
to finish our interview.
So thank you so much
for taking the time
to teach us and talk
to us about Helm
and charts and all
the nautical puns.
MATTHEW BUTCHER: Yeah, thank you
guys very much for having us.
MICHELLE NOORALI: Thanks.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks so much for
such an excellent interview,
Michelle and Matthew.
That was fantastic.
I'm really, really excited
to sit down and play
with Helm now.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
that was lots of fun.
And actually, once we
finished the interview,
we were discussing
about something
really cool that
we did not mention,
which is something that we used
as a cool thing of the week
a couple months ago, probably.
It is the little
guide to Kubernetes
that came up from the
same hackathon as Helm.
So we'll have a link on that.
But it's basically
the cutest guide
to learning Kubernetes
you could ever imagine.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
adorable illustrated.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And it is actually
technically accurate.
So, yea.
Yep.
Definitely worth checking.
So I think it's time to go
for our question of the week.
So the question
of the week today
is about Docker
images in the cloud.
And basically, it is,
OK, so I have an image
that I want to build regularly.
So imagine that, for
instance, you have something.
You have a project.
And every single time you
have a comment on GitHub,
you want to create a new image.
And there's ways of doing this.
But is there a Google Cloud
Platform way of doing it?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so there is
totally a Google Cloud Platform
way of doing it.
We have this service,
it's currently in beta,
called Google Cloud
Container Builder.
It is literally exactly
what you described it as.
It's a REST API that you can
send a series of commands to.
And the final output is
a Docker container image,
which then gets served up to
gcr.io, our Google Container
Registry.
And so it's a really
nice way of if you're
using Google
Container's Registries
and you have like
a CI or CD system
or some sort of automation
for building these container
images, it's an easy way
of basically saying, hey,
I would like to
build one of those.
Push that up into the
Container Registry.
And then I want to
serve that maybe
to Container Engine,
Compute Engine, App Engine,
Flexible Environment,
anywhere from there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I think
that it is a pretty interesting
thing to mention a little
bit about Google Container
Registry.
So Google Container
Registry, for those
that might have
never heard about it,
it is just a Container Registry.
So nothing really
fancy in there.
But it is private.
So only your project, your
Google Cloud Platform project
has access to it.
So it basically removes
all the issues on, oh, I
want to have a Docker image.
And I want to be able to
pull it from somewhere.
But I want to make it public.
I don't want other
people to see it.
So it is a very good
solution for that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and of course,
that also ties into all of
our security stuff as well.
So you already know it's secure.
And you can control who
accesses it and whatnot.
So it's pretty awesome.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it's
also in the same network.
So the deployment will be
faster and all the goodness.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
So that's pretty cool.
All right.
I think that kind of
brings us to our end.
What are you up to?
Where you going?
What are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So by the
time the podcast comes out,
I'll be probably on my way to
the airport to fly to Brazil.
I'll be going to Florianopolis
to speak at GopherCon Brasil.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And the
week after that, I'll
still be in Brazil,
this time in Sao Paulo
to speak and actually kind of
organize, which is lots of fun.
GCP NEXT Sao Paulo,
we're going to be talking
about all the new things
that we're working on
for Google Cloud Platform.
So the keynote will
be live stream.
So we'll have a link to that.
So in case you want to check it
out, that will be November 10.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing a lot
less than that, thankfully.
So when this comes out, I will
be at the Unite Conference,
the Unity Conference.
I'll just be attending.
So please feel
free to say hello.
After that, I think I'm done.
I think I'm not traveling
again for a while.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Wow.
MARK MANDEL: I say that now.
But it'll change.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I was
going to say, wow, so lazy.
But at the same time,
I don't believe you.
So thanks again one more
time for recording an episode
with me.
And this is actually
our number 50 episode--
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --which
is kind of crazy.
MARK MANDEL: That's amazing.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and we just passed
our first anniversary
recording at podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
the first one.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
It's been amazing.
Yeah, it's been a
long, long time.
Yeah.
And since then, I lost
my accent completely.
MARK MANDEL: Completely.
I don't hear it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Like you.
Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, so thank you.
And thank you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
see you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]